merci jean continue de parler de noces
ou maintenant avec le calendrier de
notre nouvelle monnaie l'euro a expliqué
ce matin par laurent fabius le ministre
de l'économie et des finances on sait
que l'euro c'est pour janvier 2002 avant
un petit peu comme pour le nouveau franc
étape par étape
il faut s'y habituer et comme d'habitude
ya du retard par exemple à peine 6% des
petites et moyennes entreprises sont
déjà passés à l'euro seulement alors
explications sur cette campagne
d'information florence griffon et jean
louis goût sert l'euro pour l'ensemble
des consommateurs c'est encore un peu
flou ici on pratique le double
étiquetage et pourtant tout le monde ne
sait pas exactement combien fait un euro
vulve et précisément 1 euro équivaut à 6
francs 55957 du coup les conversions ne
sont pas toujours facile il faut que je
dise un parti 50
alors donc 72 départs 6 2 rassurez-vous
l'euro ce n'est pas pour tout de suite
son arrivée dans votre porte monnaie se
fera d'abord dans un an le 15 décembre
chaque français pour acheter une
pochette en euros pour 100 francs
vous pourrez acquérir l'équivalent en
euros
et ça permettra d'avoir des euros dans
sa poche un petit peu avant le 1er
janvier 2002 où pourra commencer à
l'utiliser
ce sera les premiers jours car le 1er
janvier 2002 l'euro entre officiellement
en vigueur au côté du franc s'ensuit une
période de sept semaines de transition
c'est sans doute là qu'il y aura le plus
de difficultés les français en
profiteront pour rendre leurs francs 18
février 2002 le rideau tombe sur le
franc l'euro règne selon m les français
eux pensons sans doute encore longtemps